there's no courage in naivety because
you don't know what there is
to stop you you don't know what dangers
you might apprehend
but to be aware of what it is that your
problem is so to be
alert existentially let's say or to be
fully self-conscious means that you're
perfectly aware of
your limitations and how you might be
hurt and then to make the decision to
move forward into the unknown and the
land of the stranger anyways that's the
i would say that's one of the secrets to
a good life and i can say that really
without
fear of contradiction i would i would
say because the clinical literature on
this is very
very very clear what you do with people
who are afraid and to some degree
depressed but certainly anxious
is you lay out what what they're anxious
about first of all
in detail what is it that you're afraid
of what might happen
and then you decompose it into small
problems
hypothetically manageable problems and
then you have
the person expose themselves to the
thing that they're afraid of
and what happens isn't that they get
less afraid that isn't what the clinical
literature
indicates exactly what happens instead
is they get braver
and that's not the same thing right
because if you get less afraid it's like
well the world isn't as dangerous as i
thought it was you know
silly me if you get braver that's not
what happens what happens is yeah the
damn world's just as dangerous as i
thought or maybe it's even more
dangerous than i thought
but it turns out that there's something
in me that responds to taking that on as
a voluntary challenge
and grows and thrives as a consequence
and there's no doubt about this
even the psychophysiological findings
are quite clear if you
if you can if you impose
a stressor on two groups of people and
on one group the stressor is imposed
involuntarily
and on the other group the stressor is
picked up voluntarily
the people who pick up the stressor
voluntary voluntarily use a whole
different psychophysiological system to
deal with it
they use the system that's associated
with approach and challenge
and not the system that's associated
with defensive
aggression and withdrawal and the system
that is associated with challenges much
more associated with positive emotion
and much less associated with negative
emotion it's also much less
hard on you because the the defensive
posturing system the prey animal system
man when that thing kicks in it's all
systems are go for you you know
your the gas is pushed down to the or
the pedals push down to the metal and
the brakes are on
you're using future resources that you
could be storing for future time right
now in the present to ready yourself for
emergency
so there's there's there's nothing
simple or trivial at all about the idea
of being called to move
forthrightly forward into the strange
and the unknown
and there's a real adventure that's
associated with that right so
that's an exciting thing which is part
of the reason why people travel
and then also to see yourself as the
sort of creature that can do that
is willing to do that on a habitual
basis is also
the right kind of tonic for i hate this
word for your self-esteem
you know because the self-esteem has
nothing to do with feeling good about
yourself
as i already mentioned there isn't
necessarily a reason why a priori
you should just feel good about yourself
but if you can view yourself
acting in a courageous and forthright
manner and encountering the world and
trying to improve your lot
and and and taking risks you know in a
non-naive way well then you have
something that you can
comfort yourself with at night when
you're wondering what the whole damn
point of is
of your futile and miserable life and so
and that's necessary because it's often
the case that you wake up at four in the
morning or at least sometimes the case
that you wake up at four in the morning
when things haven't been going that well
and wonder just what the hell the point
is of your futile and miserable life
you have to have something real to set
against that it can't be just
rationalizations about how you know
you're a valuable person among others
even though that's true that's not good
enough
you need something that's more realistic
to set a against that and observing
courage in yourself is definitely one of
the things that
that that can help you sleep soundly at
night when when things are destabilized
a little bit around you